a little pouch of pudding they're
squishy it looks like like a half and a
half right it like that is really gross
Pocari sweat
this drink is named sweat nope like a
little bit lemony like really flat
sprite you thought it was gonna be
carbonated it's not that could be
drinking something swear right now but
there's ions in it I don't know what
this thing is that looks like me after a
rough night I don't get the relevance of
this guy
is this like man flavored like a
watermelon gummy with glitter on it it
tastes like Bath & Body Works who
decided on that what do you even do with
this you don't eat this do you open it
okay like I have to like bite it off I'm
sure like it's not strange if you know
what you're doing it tastes like video
game fruit cap that's fun this is this
is gonna be good oh it looks awful on
the inside
except this screams what flavor is cream
why would you do those two Kit Kat I'm
gonna assume that maybe it's healthier
for you since it's green the color can
throw you off this actually pretty good
it tastes sort of like a yogurt covered
pretzel
I can smell it through the back that
dude I don't think I can do this one no
one eats this is a snack
haha I don't think I can eat the head I
can't do this I'm not strong enough and
I really want to like these